frantic search and rescue efforts are
underway in India after one of the worst
rail collisions in recent history more
than 280 people were killed and 900 were
wounded in the crash involving two
passenger trains and a freight train
this morning there's fear the death toll
will climb as Rescuers sift through the
wreckage in the Eastern State of Odessa
the state's chief minister has declared
today a day of mourning Rainey in
ascencio has more
as Rescuers pull in from the wreckage
this man is lucky to be alive
the less fortunate pulled out unmoving
by bystanders the dead laid out next to
the tracks it's the latest in a string
of trained tragedies in India which have
claimed more than one thousand lives in
the past two decades this surge of
wounded and dazed victims overwhelming
small local hospitals
something when everything in the train
started flying around said this Survivor
people fell all over each other as Dawn
broke search and rescue teams ramped up
their efforts with sniffer dogs and
cutting equipment to find and free the
living and the dead still trapped in the
mangled Heap prime minister Narendra
Modi briefed in New Delhi will visit the
crash site and the injured today and
faces fresh criticism of Decades of
government neglect of India's vast 40
000 Mile Rail Network and its tragic
consequences for CBS Saturday morning
Remy inocencio London